third question that came in this week
how likely is it that any president is
really going to pack the court and add
seats to the Supreme Court so this is an
interesting question because this is
often mentioned when at any time we talk
about the Supreme Court invariably
the question comes up about you know if
Mitch McConnell is going to hold the
seat for a year so Barack Obama can't
put in Merrick garland and Donald Trump
gets to put in Neel Gorsuch next time
there's a Democratic president that
person he or she should just add seats
to the Supreme Court because you can do
that and that way you know if it ends up
being 7 - you just add a bunch of
justices and all of a sudden you've got
a left-leaning majority I think that the
risk of doing it and and the reason it's
not been done it recently is that if a
Democratic president were to add seats
to the Supreme Court and for example
Republicans still control the Senate
Republicans can hold up the
confirmations of all of the lower court
appointees most cases never make it to
the Supreme Court and the lower court
just judges are extremely important and
you could potentially fuel number one
Republicans just obstructing every
single one of your actual selections and
number two every time we have a new
president they're going to add seats to
the Supreme Court I just don't know that
that's the right way to go there's
things that need to be changed for
example there should not have been a
mechanism for Mitch McConnell to hold
the seat open that could have been
filled by Merrick garland filled with
Merrick garland by Barack Obama for a
year it just shouldn't be allowed to do
that there should be you know some some
process and you can think of 10
different ways that it could be done
where that's not possible
we could potentially be looking at
ending lifetime appointments for Supreme
Court justices now I know that there are
good arguments on both sides one of them
being if a Supreme Court justice is to
be truly independent they must not have
on their minds even subconsciously the
possibility that they may work in
industry after they are out of the
Supreme Court where they are
adjudicating a case and that may be a
factor and how I get that but there's
probably ways to deal with that which
would solve the issue of lifetime
appointments where you're essentially
waiting for people to die or to be so
elderly that they can't do the job
anymore and the timing of everything
it's a very ugly system in a sense so I
don't you know I know that it's
discussed quite a bit
I don't expect Donald Trump to pack the
Supreme Court if he wins a second term
I don't expect Joe Biden to add Supreme
Court justices if he were to defeat
Donald Trump in November it's a fraud
and complicated issue that requires more
exploration but I do think there are
other changes that should be made to the
Supreme Court that would not necessarily
lead to this just persistent race to the
bottom or race to the top or every time
you get a new president they say let's
add to and I'll select them and of
course again if you don't have control
of the Senate the other party could
block your selections to those new seats
as well so complicated issue I would
love to hear your thoughts on it we will
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today if you've not yet had the pleasure
of watching or listening to the
award-winning bonus show grab a
membership at join pakman.com